genius brain listeners guess what our
podcast is brought to you by the
farmer's dog you guys know I have a
little pup pup and I care about what my
pup pup eats so much because I love her
stupid little face well you can get 50
off your first box of fresh healthy food
at the farmersdog.com genius plus you
get free shipping just go to
thefarmersdog.com jeans to get 50 off
that's the farmersdog.com genius
it's hard because I remember just um
so after that happened I gave it a try
because she was genuinely
apologetic and I just remember just
thinking like I don't know if I could
be with somebody where I have to
second-guess every single motive and it
was just so exhausting it was very very
very difficult and having that
conversation with her where eventually
you know I just told like this
isn't going to work out in five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast we are back in the studio
with Studio 71 and we have a reoccurring
guest here Liz we therapist
extraordinaire and on this podcast I
talk about therapy a lot I've been I've
been going to therapy for a very long
time right
um and I think that uh some because I
one of the sponsors of this podcast is
uh better help and I always get like a
couple of comments where they go do you
actually take therapy I for sure have
been taking therapy for a very long time
and I think uh it started when I was
really younger because it started with a
lot of counseling first and from
counseling to anger management and then
from that to therapy so when I was a kid
I used to get you know I had anger
issues because this is how you solve a
lot of our problems and then
as I got older I didn't know how to
figure out why I was so mad all the damn
time and then from the counselor to
anger management like have you tried
therapy I was like well I thought this
was [__] therapy no this isn't
therapy so I I went to therapy and then
that kind of helped me
um fix my relationship with my dad a lot
because it taught me a lot of like
empathy which I don't think I had a lot
when I was younger because when you're
young you're kind of thinking especially
from like I think from a parent to kid
perspective it's always oh you don't you
don't care about how I feel and then
they you know the therapist kind of put
it in the perspective of have you ever
thought about how your dad felt I was
like it doesn't [__] matter you know
like how do I feel but that kind of kind
of took the uh was the start of me going
to therapy pretty regularly or whenever
I needed just to have it in my back
pocket so you know having you on I think
a lot of people really did resonate with
oh just trying therapy out and I think
that's like the the hardest like first
step
um whether it's because of fear of them
finding out things that they don't want
to be affirmed or reaffirmed or if they
just don't believe in the process right
and I I understand I think it's a very
scary thing right I think being
introspective scares a lot of people
right yeah and you also don't know what
you're going to impact it's kind of
scary 100 you talk a little closer to
the mic let's get a little closer there
we go even closer than that and I think
yeah a lot of people found me and it was
their first time going to therapy so
that was really exciting I never thought
that they should or they thought about
it but you know they weren't sure but I
think after watching you and and me they
felt like okay yeah this is maybe
something I should try yeah and you know
for a lot of young Asian Americans to
I just don't think that therapy is
something
um
people tend to put in the Forefront of
what they need in their lives right so
there's physical health there's there's
money Financial stability but mental
health is always right here because
they're in I feel like for a lot of
people they think oh well if this stuff
here is fixed I'll be happy but you know
for a lot of people especially
even the friends around me or even
people who are close to me after they
gained a certain level of success the
feelings stay the same you know
everything is just a quick Band-Aid when
we had a lot of time to ourselves
specifically during pandemic and I said
this multiple times I know a lot of
people that were losing their damn Minds
only because all the distractions that
they had before they weren't there
anymore going out to drink and hanging
out with their friends and then they
were just in this room just stuck with
their thoughts the whole day coping
skills gone yeah everything is gone and
I just remember I saw a lot of my
friends kind of just fall apart at the
seams and the good thing about that is
that they started going to therapy like
oh maybe I should try this whole therapy
thing out yeah and it was just a safe
space like one of my friends said it the
best is like I tell things to my
therapist that I don't even tell my wife
my brother my sisters or even my parents
I just feel like I can't even if they if
even if they would be accepting which I
feel like they would she says like I
can't do it I don't know why but to my
I'll say whatever I'll be able to
process these thoughts and it's a really
fun safe space right right
so today
um we wanted to go over the topic of
well there's a couple of topics right
um specifically I um you know Liz
brought this up but
let's talk about toxic and abusive
relationships right which I feel that
um a lot of people either have been
through one but the idea of recognizing
it and then healing from it are two
different things that you know people
just don't really address right and I
think that
it's hard to figure out when you're in a
toxic relationship especially when
you're in the thick of it yeah you know
so for you
um
what is like something that you feel is
or you know what is a sign of a toxic
relationship because I feel like that's
really hard to Define for me you know
people will ask us on the podcast like
I'm in a toxic relationship like I don't
I don't know how to define that you know
because everybody's definition of what
that is you know tends to vary you know
yeah so talk closer to the mic okay so I
would say there are many different signs
that you can look out for but the first
thing
um I think
pay attention to how you feel in the
relationship how they make you feel so
if you feel insecure in the relationship
I'm not talking about
your self-esteem it's more about
um I do you know their true intention of
you know about you or of the
relationship
um do you feel like they can just
disappear tomorrow
um
or maybe they ghost you sometimes and
they come back and you know you feel
like okay well where's this going I have
no idea
um so that probably is a really bad sign
right because you can't quite attach to
them so you'll feel insecure insecurely
attached in the relationship so I'll pay
attention to that
um
and I think it's really more about
how how do you feel when you're with
someone right do they make you feel good
you know they
um are they positive around you you know
they lift you up or do they put you down
you know
um maybe there's some disrespect too
um
I think this respect can come in many
different ways but yeah so so
have you ever like
had clientele word
like the relationship from what you've
heard from these stories right where it
seems very toxic would you do you have
to address it at the point or do you let
them kind of come to that conclusion
themselves only because like you know
when you have conversation with friends
I feel like sometimes we're like hey I
don't think this person is good for you
but if you say something you kind of
feel like they feel that you are against
them it always makes me feel awkward
right
yeah
delicate balance because we always want
clients to find their own truth
and we all have that innate power to do
that we have our inner intelligence that
would if we trust it it will tell us
right
um
so
I think I generally try to really guide
clients to kind of go there
um
but sometimes I do see really abusive
relationships and I I'll call them out
sometimes the abuser in the relationship
hey that sounds very abusive things like
that and in that moment the partners
feel validated right oh I thought this
was really bad but you know my partner
has been gaslighting me this whole time
so I didn't think it was abusive you
know because he kept telling me I was
just being sensitive you know so they
start thinking right oh okay maybe this
is something I need to really start
thinking about so they do their own
research and maybe they'll come back and
start talking about a little bit more
you know so I think that's how they
start finding their own voice and learn
you know what's healthy for them and
what's not healthy instead of kind of
being told what the truth is by their
abusive partner I think
you know when you know just being around
other couples who you know during
pandemic they tend to a lot of them
split
um I don't know whether it's because
they never had to spend this much time
with their significant other in such a
close space but they were finding out a
lot of things that they either like or
disliked about them right I wonder
I wonder I mean for me I think I'm very
different so when I
tend to be in bad situations whether
it's a friendship or you know a personal
relationship or anything else
um maybe it's because this is how my
parents are or my mom and dad are like
they're very like cut throat straight to
the point so if things
aren't feeling good it's addressed right
um how do people get into this situation
where they're in this bad relationship
but say somehow rationalize it as if
it's something that's very very healthy
because everybody can see certain things
from the outside that's objectively
really bad right right so in my mind it
always boggles my mind like I can't
figure it's like how did you get here to
this point and why you know yeah uh
that's a really difficult thing to
understand
um but a lot of times Partners who end
up with very abusive or toxic Partners
they had maybe their attachment figures
and from childhood who behaved in
similar way right so if you were abused
as a child you know verbal abuse was a
thing just thrown out all the time or
emotion abuse or even
your maybe your dad cheated on your mom
all the time so that's kind of like
normalized right so that's what love
means to you so you don't maybe think
it's too bad right so
um there's that and then another thing
is cognitive dissonance where where um
you want to believe certain thing and
you see something else but you're
rationalizing it because you want to see
this right so you want to be in a
relationship you experience that oh yeah
I want to be in a happy respectful
healthy relationship my partner behaves
this way
but I want to be here so I make you know
excuses for them not consciously
subconsciously so that I can still be
here right and it happens almost like
kind of a survival skill right
um I want to be with someone who I love
and
I want to keep that so it's kind of your
brain kind of does it kind of naturally
so you have to start noticing that
right when when you
I I get a lot of questions asking about
like how to address this with people
like Partners right and I I always have
I always struggle with this because I
don't know how to tell people how to do
it because I don't suggest people do it
the way that I do it because I'm a
little I'm very straightforward right
um and not everybody has that and I
always tell people like I have social
anxiety like it's pretty [__] crazy
but I
kind of developed this practice of like
just telling myself you're not gonna die
just do it you're not gonna die just do
it so the the end result is always that
I do end up doing it and nothing happens
so it just kind of reaffirms the fact
that you could do it again and again and
again and um I I'll give people examples
of okay like I had to confront this
person they're like I wish I could do it
as easy as you I'm like it's not easy
it's it's hard it's it makes my skin cry
make it extremely easy like easy yeah it
just makes my skin crawl even now when I
do stand-up
um I go on stage before I go it feels
like I'm gonna die if till this day I've
been doing it since I was like 16 years
old it feels like I'm going to die every
time my palms are sweaty and my friends
have witnessed this and they've seen me
do stand up for years and they go dude
since the first time I've seen you did
since you were 16 till now you look like
you're going to throw up like no matter
what the stage how many people come out
like you look a wreck I'm like because I
just I feel the same emotions every time
because of the anxiety that I get and it
just like all these thoughts start to
eat me up so
when people have to address this with
their partner right in a more
interpersonal space rather than just
stand up like what would what would be a
a method that you could suggest to
people who have trouble confronting
people like what is a way that they can
do it
so I mean I think when
we're thinking about
partner you're already sensing hey this
is not right for me right something's
not working this is not healthy so that
means to me that you already thought
about what your boundaries are what
healthy relationship looks like to you
and
um you're not seeing that or there are
some things that kind of goes against it
so you want to bring that up to your
partner so if you talk about you this is
who I am this is what I need this these
are my boundaries it lands a lot better
to the partner rather than
you know I don't know people
Google a lot you know or you watch
YouTube and they say oh I I read all
these you know all these things and it
feels like an attack rather than
engaging engaging your partner in a
conversation so
um it might look like hey
um
I really
feel uncomfortable when you raise your
voice when we get into an argument
can we try not to do that right so
you're using kind of like we language
and you're talking about your feelings
rather than you always yell you know you
go crazy whenever we argue right even if
it feels very unhealthy we can't still
and address it in an unhealthy manner we
have to still do it in healthy manner I
feel that's really hard like when you're
very emotional in the situation yeah to
kind of Bring It Back Down to Earth and
then have like a civil discussion
because if things are already boiling
over it's it's very hard and I found
this when I was younger too it was hard
for me to be the bigger person like
sometimes in my mind I'm thinking to
myself I know that if I say this this
conversation is going to get really bad
but I'm gonna say you know and that's
like the most difficult part because you
know we said what's that class of saying
like hurt people hurt people so you hurt
me I want to make sure you feel the same
way I feel you know yeah right so yeah
usually what I recommend to my clients
is that take a time out you know
um cool down at least for 20 minutes go
for a walk talk to your friend whatever
you need to do to not be in that space
because if you're that in that activated
space you're going to just react react
and keep escalating right so take a
break and when you feel calmer
you can address it calmly hey this is
what I need from you next time when you
get really upset
maybe we both need to take time out and
then we'll re-engage later when we're
ready you know so that's you kind of
setting your boundaries hey this is not
okay and this is what I need from you
right so if we approach that in that way
even if your partner
um
is being abusive to you
um you're addressing it in the right way
right is it going to be accepted or
received very well and maybe not you're
with an abusive partner yeah it's very
much likely that you're going to be a
guest lit and that's one of the signs
that you should look out for as well so
if this partner were to say Hey you
um I I really don't feel comfortable
when you raise your voice can you blah
blah blah blah and then all of a sudden
they go well you make me that way right
it's because of your response yeah it's
because of you because you may drive me
crazy right or
um you always do that too you know not
taking responsibility
um or when I never do that yeah yeah
yeah yeah and you go crazy like oh my
God I should have recorded this
conversation you know they always say
they never did that or whatnot right so
yeah it's difficult
it doesn't really mean that anything
going anything is going to change even
if you address it if you are within you
know toxic or abusive partner yeah so
what if you like set that boundary and
it doesn't work what is what is the next
step because I feel like for me it was
just pretty much like all right we're
breaking up you know because it was
pretty straightforward like for example
um I was with somebody uh prior to my
wife who
I had a short temper right but the one
thing that I would ask for it's like
if I get really mad I need you to not
touch me and I need you to go away so I
just I gotta Breathe Right space I need
space and this girl would always be like
no like I I can help you I'm like you
you can help me by getting away right
because right now nothing is good like
something bad happened earlier in the
day and then you came here you came at
me you started chewing me out and now
I'm just about to explode and she goes
no I'll give you a hug and I'm like I
need you not to touch me and then she
would hug me and it would make me even
more angry and then it would get into an
argument of like well why are you mad at
me when I'm trying to help I'm like but
you're not helping me though you know
and I think that was for me I was like
oh you just want to do things the way
you want to do things right you know
even if it's not beneficial to me right
so I think that was like how do I like
what would be the next step after that I
mean that's really dangerous right when
someone's assuming that I know better
than you what you need right yeah I'm
not in your body but I know better than
you so I'm gonna do but I think it's
right so so yeah that is a bad sign
um I usually recommend even for myself I
think I try to set healthy boundaries
several times and then see what kind of
response I get right if I get very
I mean welcoming response hey I didn't
know that's how I made you feel I'm
really sorry that I made you feel that
way thank you for sharing that with me
let's work on it together thanks for you
know calling that in or something like
that that's a good response right so
that means you have a partner who's
ready to work with you and acknowledging
I make mistakes I have faults and so do
you but we can work on it and get better
together right start building healthy
relationship but if you get constantly
the gas lighting or resistance right no
that's not what you need right
um no I never do that no it's it's you
or you're crazy you're too sensitive
over and over and over again then you
have to really start thinking about is
this what I want right if I keep staying
in this relationship and keep getting
same response
then I'm doing this to myself right so
um my
um
I guess suggestion would be try to
really figure out you know that issue is
that a deal breaker is it really
important part of the relationship you
know I need to feel validated by my
partner or I need to have healthy style
of communication that's like number one
thing but I can't have that with my
partner then maybe you need to you know
stay true to yourself and go find it
somewhere else because you're not going
to get it here right do you feel that a
lot of people sometimes they choose to
stay in relationships that aren't great
for them because time is a huge Factor
whether they feel like they're getting
older or I put so much like investment
into this human being that it'd be a
waste to let it go now is that something
that you have to deal with a lot
yeah I think that plays a big part
um for women especially because
they're yeah biological clock is ticking
stuff like that but I think
bigger factor for me is that people see
some changes and they keep expecting
they'll see more so it's not that you
don't see any changes usually people
will see
tiny increments right and so now
you have hope right okay they changed a
little bit so maybe they'll really
change one day
um so I think that's why the people stay
longer than they should
um I think I read something about
jackpot effect or something like that
um where they give you the numbers are
very very close to Jackpot so you think
like okay I'm almost there right I won
five dollars so maybe next time I'll own
a thousand dollars or whatever so you
keep thinking like okay it's gonna
happen it's gonna we're so close
so
yeah I think it's just
you being hopeful and maybe trying to be
a nice person
giving them benefit of Doubt one more
time I feel a lot of a lot of like when
I was younger a lot of my girlfriends
would do that with guys like it almost
felt like there were these guys who were
projects right so it would be along the
lines of
you don't know him like I do that was
like the classic phrase I would always
hear right it's like I think I know him
better than you do yeah you know because
you see this side that he puts out to
you because he wants you to love him I
see everything you know from an outside
perspective so for example there was
this um
guy who well they got married and they
got divorced right none of us were
surprised and it was just from this one
thing where um we were all going
um karaokeing and then we were hanging
out having a few drinks and he got drunk
and I remember this I'll forever
remember this because I got really
pissed she was singing with uh one of
our other guy friends
um and they were singing a song together
they both sing really well
um as they were singing he took her
aside and he started chewing her out
because she was having fun with another
guy right but this is a guy by the way
they've been friends since they were
like in kindergarten you know and by the
way he's married and his wife is there
you know what I mean they've all known
each other for a while and
you know having the conversation with it
I was like hey uh this might be a
problem because number one I didn't like
the way that he grabbed her because he
shouldn't have grabbed her in the first
place
um and she said the classic response
which was like listen like you know he
was drinking and you know you know maybe
I got a little too close to him and I'm
like why are you why are you the [__]
in this in this situation and I could
never figure it out and when they when
they ended up getting married I was like
oh maybe they they figured it out mom
hold they get divorced for the same
reasons he was you know abusive like
verbally more verbally than physically
from from what she told me after a few
years after they got divorced like he
would
um
anytime she would have fun without him
it was like why are you having fun when
I should be like the source like the
center of your world like you're having
more fun with other people than you are
with me how come you don't laugh with me
like you do with you know whether it's a
guy or a girl because originally I
thought it was just for guys right but
it was any interpersonal relationship
outside of him I'm like bro she had a
life without you you're you're actually
relatively new in this scene we've known
her for well for me at the time it was
like five years but you've at the time I
mean they've had to be together less
than a year at that point you know so in
my mind I'm thinking how does how does
one get to that point where
how do people like that get in
relationships like how do you do it you
know I mean because in my mind I'm like
you're not that good looking you're not
a great person either so like he's some
and he's awesome too like she's like one
of those girls that everybody wanted to
get with because she was such a cool
person so I'm like how does she get
duped into getting together with this
guy to the point of marriage you know
I've never been able to figure that out
I mean she doesn't get it she goes I
don't know what I saw in him I'm like I
don't know either you know
there must have been something that was
very Charming you know maybe he love
bombed her in the beginning
um really I mean those are the things
that a lot of narcissists do
um make you feel like you're the center
of the world you know in their world or
um there's no one else but you they make
you feel like
um no one else can love you like that
but they also do all these other things
and so they're not always bad right
because if they're always bad you won't
stay with them so they have these three
immune qualities and
um you kind of battle okay well they do
this and they're great in these ways and
they do all these bad things but I try
to not look at that because I want to
stay with this person
um but yeah I think that person kind of
represents a lot of the different things
um that we can call it as like unhealthy
Behavior right
um that expression of jealousy
jealousy is a normal human feeling but
what we do with it that kind of
determines if you're healthy or not
right
um
if if you can acknowledge it and maybe
even joke about it with your partner
like oh that guy was totally looking at
you you know oh my wife's hot like you
know something like that healthy right
but if you get all of a sudden very
suspicious you know
um and you don't talk about it or maybe
you get really accusatory you know are
you sleeping with someone else you know
I think all those girls were like trying
to get your number you must be doing
something or something like that right
that's
um
unhealthy way so there are like a
certain healthy amounts of like jealousy
like when you're you know you're
attached to somebody it's okay to feel
like oh what the [__] you know yeah yeah
totally I mean I I think it that we
since we're you know all human beings it
it it's bound to happen right
um
I think other people might find your
partner very attractive too right so you
might feel that you know oh there's that
energy like oh yeah he likes her yeah
yeah he thinks she's cool
and
maybe it's the combination of both like
stay away from her you know but also
like oh kind of proud you know yeah
because I remember when I was younger
too and
um with you know when I had my very
first girlfriend I'm super young but
just remembering who that person was
where it was like if she spoke to
anybody that wasn't me it's like oh she
she likes him way more than me yeah I
mean and it would like eat me up as a
kid but you know obviously after we
broke up you know I sobered up I was
like what the hell are you doing like
that's so bad this is very very
unhealthy and I I think for me what I
kind of rationalized to was just that I
didn't have a value system for myself so
she was always the person that was out
of my reach that I was undeserving of so
it's easy for somebody to go and take
her because I'm her charity case you
know so that's what it always felt like
and so when we broke up and then you
know we were off and on for like a year
or two and then we kind of I'm like what
19 years old 20 years old at that point
I just had a moment I was like oh you
you don't you don't like yourself enough
you know like you your definition of
your value is based on what what she
thinks of you so if she is with you
you're worth something if she likes you
then that means you're a good person but
when when when she was when she uh
dumped me I'm like oh I'm not I have no
value anymore so my then it started to I
started understanding like oh I probably
wasn't a very good person to her because
of the way that I would be hyper
possessive of her right so I made I
would make her probably you know
hindsight is 20 20 but this is you know
after we broke up I realized oh maybe I
probably made her feel bad with my words
whenever she would hang out with
somebody else right and I think I mean
it did kind of get reaffirmed because
she did cheat on me but you know but you
know there is like a point of I don't
know why I think like this now but I I
do take a little I have to take personal
responsibility because it makes me feel
like I have some type of control in this
right or I feel like no I'm not
responsible for her cheating me but I
did create an unhealthy environment for
her where she felt that she had to
um she needed something from somebody
else that she wasn't getting from me
right and I feel like from that point on
I was just very aware of how I felt like
a little more in tune with my personal
emotions right so it's like oh you're
you're a little a little needy man you
know like how come you don't how come
you can't just hang out with your own
friends and then find fulfillment and
other things outside of this one person
and I think that was like a very
sobering moment for me where I was like
oh you don't you don't care about
yourself right you only care about what
she thinks of you and then now you have
value you know yeah that's really great
you had a great insight into your own
behavior
um realized oh I need to work on myself
if I don't want to feel that way like
I'm I'm not good I'm not worthy that's
me that's not her it's my work but I
think you might be taking a little bit
more responsibility than you should
um her action is her action no one made
her do it you know yeah if we get to
talk about infidelity later you know I
would I would talk about that
um in more deeper we get in there right
now yeah I mean infidelity that's
something that people say a lot like you
know once you do it
um because I wasn't getting sex or
because you don't talk to me anymore or
I was really stressed at work something
right there's always a reason right
and even though sometimes maybe you
don't have any intention to justify it
you're just trying to get your partner
to understand where you are it feels
like that right so
um it's really important when you're
trying to heal front infidelity you're
taking 100 responsibility
I think that's like the like if nobody
has ever some people haven't been
cheated on but like being cheated I just
remember it was terrible like it was
like one of the worst feelings I've ever
felt there's like two of two of these
moments that if whenever I act like if I
wanted to feel despair I could take from
these two things right it was the first
time I ever got dumped as a teenager
right and I just remember I can't I
can't reenact how it felt but I do
remember if feeling like somebody took
my heart and it just like fell to the
bottom of my stomach it was just such a
specific feeling right and I've never
felt that since then right and whether
it's because I guarded myself from ever
wanting to feel like it did I went from
like okay
lover boy loves too much to like I don't
ever want to look at it you know like
the pendulum will go from here all the
way to here right so anything that this
person was I'm gonna be the exact
opposite I'm like the girl that I'm
gonna date is going to be nothing like
her look nothing like her have different
interests turns out I hated this other
person because she was a fine person
like she was fine you know
um and like I think the it's hard to
describe what
like how do you get over that type of
stuff because for me it was it was it
was time
and then
I think like I say I always try to maybe
rationalize okay maybe what is my
responsibility in this to a certain
extent right because I got cheated on
twice right the second time I got
cheated on was when
um
I don't want to take like this one I
don't feel like I take too much
responsibility it's just more of the
fact that it was because of my job in my
career like I was always gone you know
24 7. and I think what she wanted out of
a partner was somebody who was more who
kind of made her feel wanted right but
in my mind I think because of that past
relationship I was like I don't want to
be too needy you know so that made her
feel like she wasn't wanted at all and
she lashed out in the worst way possible
and
that was like the weird I just remember
her calling me telling tell me what she
did and I was like what the [__]
I didn't do this and it still happened
and I went here and it happened this way
too so it was like this weird moment of
like over correction right
there was a lot of things that were good
here but I only took from the bad things
and I tried to over correct and I went
far over here or the person that I felt
like she wasn't important to me at all
but I was like you were important I just
didn't want to smother you you know it
was just a weird weird moment you know
sad it's yeah because you didn't know
how to maybe find that balance between
the two right yeah I want to be
available and supported partner who's
affectionate and
um
you know who is not afraid to show it
versus
I'm guarded I don't do love I don't do
feelings like right
um closed very close off
there is happy medium that's the secure
um style right and I think that's
probably where you are now after doing
all the work but yeah to answer your
question healing from infidelity is
extremely hard work and it can happen in
different ways sometimes you heal on
your own you have to get out of this
relationship and just focus on your own
healing so you heal kind of separately
sometimes people decide to heal together
um
so they come to therapy right I highly
recommend if you have experienced
infidelity in your relationship go find
help as soon as you can because it's
really difficult thing to navigate
through and it's the trust part that I
don't understand where yeah
um
I don't think I was able to trust that
person again like it just wasn't
possible for me every time I saw that
person it was like you
lied to me you know that's all I can
think about it's like you like and it
wasn't something that you lied to me for
because you didn't want to hurt my
feelings or white lies or whatever where
there was like a motive behind it it was
like you did this to make sure that I
was going to hurt and it was such a
weird experience to think about like how
could you do that to me it's all I think
about it's like how could you I would
never in a million years go out of my
way to make sure that you would feel
pain on purpose like you know when we
argue well that we fight things happen
right when we get highly emotional but
this was almost planned out that's what
it felt like to me anyways like you had
dinner with me we had meals together
when we visited each other everything
was great and then during this whole
time two two whatever two three months
and it was like boom you drop this bomb
it's like wait how did you look at me
how did you say I love you how did you
say how did we share a meal together a
bed together like how did you do this
makes me feel like you're crazy but are
you a psychopath like how did you do
this to me and like I didn't I could
never get over it right and I think
everything that you're describing right
now now that is why healing from
infidelity could be really challenging
because it's such a traumatic experience
your world gets turned upside down right
the world that you thought it was my I
have a loving partner who's faithful to
me and we have this kind of life you
know right all of a sudden boom all gone
right you have no ground to stand on
right so now you have to make sense out
of everything so your brain's trying to
catch on anything like okay was that
real was that Memorial well like what
about that moment right so you start
wondering questioning about everything
um
so
yeah it's just like
um a war veteran maybe coming back from
war you have all have all these PTSD
symptoms
it's an infidelity trauma so you have
constant Obsession about these facts you
know does it happen is it going to
happen again some people might get
really irritable or angry you know out
of the blue right or really sad
um so you see these kind of really
intense emotional response and
people feel like I don't know I
unfortunately I think the partners who
actually offending Partners sometimes
describe their partner like oh yeah they
are going crazy right now like well you
know because you made them all right you
created this yeah you know and they you
know if you haven't gone through it it's
so hard to understand so they even
um guess like their partner saying
things like just get over it you know it
happened like three years ago
um it's enough time time to heal like
you said you're gonna forgive and forget
what happened to that you know let's do
that or whatever
um yeah extremely harming it's horrible
because I remember just um
so after that happened I gave it a try
because she was genuinely
apologetic and I just remember just
thinking like I don't know if I could
be with somebody where I have to
second-guess every single motive and it
was just so exhausting it was very very
very difficult and having that
conversation with her where eventually
you know I just told like this
isn't going to work out because it also
felt too and I'm not sure if other
people who have you know been cheated on
were now on on her side it was like I
don't feel I also like this was actually
a more this was actually the bigger
factor to why I said this wasn't going
to work was because I felt now that she
couldn't be honest with me anymore
because now she wanted to be the perfect
girlfriend where disagreement we weren't
even allowed to have disagreements
because she would just be you're right
and I'm like
but now I don't know you now like I
don't know if you're now I don't know if
you're honest about anything so she was
so scared of walking an eggshell yeah
all the time and I kind of wanted to
move forward from this but it felt like
I was not with a different person not
even so much the idea of yeah there was
everything I said before but I say that
was like 20 the other 80 was
we there was no more disagreements she
wouldn't really Express her thoughts
anymore and it felt like she was trying
to say everything perfect because she
was so scared of losing me and I felt
like oh I'm not I'm never gonna get to
know you now because you're trying so
hard to gain my trust but it's in a way
where I'll I don't even know who you are
right and I remember
I was like in a bad mood or something I
said something
that wasn't good and I apologize I was
like you know what like I'm sorry and
she goes no you're my it's my fault I'm
like
no it's not you know I'm like oh but
this then I was like oh wait a minute
all our conversations are like this even
when I'm wrong or if I apologize you
somehow turn it on you because you feel
so guilty for this thing that happened
so we can't even move on from that so
that's why like I've I know a couple of
people who
have faced this but they still stay
together and you know they've asked me
too where
uh people have asked like okay if if
Mariel cheated on you would you up and
just leave her and I think I've said
that in the past if anybody cheats on me
I'm gone I don't know if that's the case
like like with her because I love her so
dearly right I don't know what the life
is without her so if she disappears and
she's gone and I've said this too I was
like by the way I say listen if you
leave me just to know just to let you
know I'm gonna be single for the rest of
my life like I'm pretty much done you
know and I say that in jest obviously
but the idea of not having that person
around is probably even a more scarier
thought than being with somebody who
cheated on me
like which is a weird thing to like say
out loud you know it's like I'd rather
be with this person who hurt me then to
be alone without this person I think
that's very common yeah because the
person that who hurt you like that is a
person who can actually fix it and make
you feel better you know make you feel
really loved too you know those two
people live in the same person so
um it's really hard to let go sometimes
when people want to leave the
relationship
um
yeah I think when
when you experience something like that
you have this kind of ideas that you
created like oh yeah cheating is
cheating means this you know and that's
not gonna work for me I'll do this if
they ever cheat on me if most of the
times I think it goes out the window
yeah yeah yeah everything changes
because you when you're in it you really
know
um it's not that easy
it's very complicated right
um and it is something that you can heal
from it just needs a lot of work and the
Betrayed partner has a lot of healing to
do and the offending partner has a lot
of they have to carry
a lot of
um I mean the bigger much much bigger
load in that healing process
especially in the beginning because the
Betrayed partner usually they're busy
surviving you know they're just trying
to like okay my like life just
disappeared right now and I have to
start building everything again I keep
questioning myself you know I I trusted
my intuition what's wrong with me I
didn't even know you know if I didn't
catch that if I didn't feel it can I
really trust myself ever again there's
just so many things right
um so
if we have the offending partner who is
very willing to help then it's so much
easier but no we don't get that all the
time yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so that's
yeah that's a little bit difficult yeah
I mean so what are some of the steps
that you would tell somebody I guess
like in that couple situation
um that would help them to get to that
healing process right because obviously
my solution was like I just can't deal
with this you know and I had to move on
because it would just eat me up every
day right I couldn't it felt like I was
drowning every day like being next to
this person felt like I was drowning
because
um I'm never present in our relationship
I'm thinking about the past and I'm
thinking about what you're going to do
to me in the future so the the present
stuff which is really important I was
never there I'm just like man I can't
believe you did this to me or what will
you do to me in the future right
so yeah sometimes I think it feels like
that and you have to make the choice
that's right for you right some some
people leave some people stay and
there's no one right way
um but we do things very kind of Step by
Step
um when they first come to us um
we try to figure out if the disclosure
has happened
usually people feel bad so bad to their
partner that they cheated
they give them like a little bit of
information first and then again later a
little bit more a little bit more that
their partner keeps asking so
they keep discovering more right and
that's so hurtful yeah it's like being
traumatized over and over and over again
I'm trying to trust you but you keep
telling me more than this you told me
that it was only once and now okay it's
three times and was it really the only
one person you know so you can't start
that way right so you have to make the
full disclosure
um and be 100 honest
yeah because I think that would kill me
if I'm like okay so it was you know two
or three times and then three months
later okay so a few months before that
I'm like what the [__] you know what I
mean like just tell me up front so we
could deal with it that would that would
literally kill me people do that [__]
is it because they're scared of the
repercussions in the beginning or like
what's the point of that like it's like
real like reopening a womb constantly oh
I would die I would literally die yeah
part of it is their own guilt you know
and part of it is oh I just feel too bad
to tell the the whole truth because it's
gonna hurt them too much right so I
usually tell them no just tell them
right now
so much more if there are other things
like trickling down later
um so we call it like trickling you know
disclosure or stagger disclosure
um you don't want that yeah so that's
the number one thing and then the second
thing is what we
um kind of talked about already really
owning your stuff right
um I know this is me I did this right
you didn't make me do it you didn't held
you know hold on to my head yeah I had
many different you know
um ways to deal with whatever I was
dealing with you weren't having sex with
me I could have gone to therapist
the negative maybe coping skill could
have been like using drugs or whatever
you have so many choices but you chose
this yeah so that's on you right so
um
rather than telling your partner why you
did what you did just own it okay that's
me it's not important why I did it but I
did it
right
if you want your partner to understand
what happened
what you feel like what led to that we
can talk about it later but you don't do
that right away in in the beginning if
you do it your partner has no patience
for that because so so fresh yeah and
they feel like okay so you're blaming me
for this right so it's my fault right
that's because that's what it sounds
like yeah right or oh so because you
felt so stressed at work that's that's
what you do I didn't do that why why do
you get to do that right so they don't
have
capacity to really understand at all
right so
um we have to do that later when you're
healed so and also
it might be true that your partner was
mean to you during that time
um or maybe that did something wrong
still we don't talk about it right away
we talk about it we say before later
um because they don't have empathy for
you right now yeah you're talking about
me yelling are you serious yeah yeah
yeah you know what you did to me yeah
yeah no I'm not going there right so it
that doesn't help so we really try to
focus on the betray Partners hurt first
and then once they're strong enough they
will be able to look at your hurt you
know have empathy for their partner
right
um so that's another thing that's
important
um and then
the something
else that we already talked about is
understanding what really infidelity
trauma is so really treating as like
okay what pts PTSD looks like and what
I'm seeing is the result of the trauma
that I inflicted to my partner so and it
takes time for them to heal from that
right so I don't say things like just
get over it already you know why are you
acting crazy
because they're going through very
traumatic event right they're still
going through it because they keep being
triggered
being in the relationship with you right
yeah that's a big trigger every single
day so you should be thankful that they
stayed with you willing to be triggered
every day right they love you that much
to you know risk that okay yeah because
I feel like if when I'm tracing back to
like how I felt it's like
if I'm remembering it it kind of felt
like
but that other person gets to have their
cake and eat it too it's like so you get
everything that you want and then you
just explode my world and I'm like I'm
just supposed to be okay with it like
how does this work out right like you so
whatever wasn't satisfied in life you
found it in another partner and then
somehow along the lines like you got
everything so you got everything you
wanted and then I'm here now left with
nothing like you
betrayed me like I don't have anything
anymore I have no trust I don't have the
person that I'm with and then it just
feels like this really just
dark place you know what I mean and like
I
that's why I always I very much
empathize with people who get cheated on
right and if you haven't felt that it's
one of the worst feelings on Earth
especially when you are committed to a
monogamous relationship that's a it's a
really hard commitment and I don't think
people really understand that right and
I didn't really get it too until I got
married and I was with somebody with
Mary we've been together for eight years
and I had no idea how hard it was yeah
you know that's it's such a difficult
difficult thing to work through because
she and I are just from two different
worlds and trying to somehow make this
Mission work together was very very
difficult and um when she started trying
out therapy
um it helped her out a lot because then
she got to understand why she is the way
that she is and why and everything why I
am the way that I am and I think that
also helped out when she actually got to
meet my family yeah and she goes oh you
guys everybody in your family is like
this I'm like I'm telling you like this
is how we are so she has a family that's
I think it's very
um stories that I would hear of typical
Korean families right so when I tell
stories about my Korean family it's not
typical at all right we're very atypical
um
like there's family politics I don't
have family politics my mom's even more
Cutthroat than I am like she's literally
like when we went to Korea uh this fast
uh spring I was like oh who do I have to
visit she goes we have 10am and that's
it other than that they all can go die I
was like why why she goes they don't
call me so you could all you only see
him that's it if they call you don't
talk to them I'm like oh okay so this is
how we work it's more oh there's a
certain set of rules that you abide by
and we hash things out
um with her family everything is kind of
swept under the rug little little looks
little a slight comment here and there
you know a little comment about the way
you dress the way you I'm like and I
would see these at some of these family
functions and I'm like oh I think this
is how a lot of families are because I
would ask other people and they're like
no your family's weird dude most family
functions are like that it's actually
pretty normal I'm like oh I didn't know
that because I don't have a big family
like that so obviously my mom made sure
of that you know so she so getting to
understand when she came over to my
house she goes oh I understand why you
why you cook so much like that's your
mom's love language like when I come to
the house it's always what do you want
to eat and then she cooks as she's
cooking for 14 people you know and then
she sits there she waits for me to take
my first bite and then before I eat it
she goes I still I'm like how I didn't
eat it you know like I don't know yet
like let me eat it and then she'll eat
it she goes
[Laughter]
back off but she's waiting for that
affirmation and I do the same thing to
her I'm like
you don't know anything about food but
she started to understand like what how
I reciprocate love and like how it how
it functions in my family and then she
goes oh I can see why you're hyper
affectionate you know why how you deal
with certain things why you like to say
things up front
um because I've seen her and her mom you
know the daughter mother relationship is
something I don't know about right and
I've seen it and I'm like yeah this is
hard to navigate because
sometimes I'll see how they how they
solve things it's like they'll get mad
at each other they'll scream they'll
just hang up and the next day they're
like how are you like what are you doing
like I don't understand how this happens
and so for her like we got to know each
other a little bit better because we
started to see each other's families
function we started empathizing a little
more it's like oh I could see why why
this is happening this way is because of
some conversation you have with your
parents and now you see how my parents
are I think meeting each other's family
and really getting to know each other
was great and one of the better things
that happened with us was
um the fact that I could speak Korean
and she was actually shocked that I
could speak Korean because I guess most
like first gen even second gen people
can't speak Korean and even when they
say they could speak Korean it's really
really bad because my in my
personally for me my Korean is terrible
genius brain listeners guess what our
podcast is brought to you by the
farmer's dog you guys know I have a
little pup pup and I care about what my
pup pup eats so much because I love her
stupid little face when you look at bags
of dog food you see pictures of bright
carrots and juicy steaks but when you
open the bag all you get are stale
smelly pellets dog food needs some fresh
thinking feed your dog the farmer's dog
it's real fresh healthy food with whole
meat and veggies gently steamed in human
grade kitchens to preserve their
nutritional value just tell them about
your dog and they'll deliver a
personalized vet develop meal plan for
as little as three dollars a day meals
arrive in pre-portioned ready to serve
packs and because they're delivered on
your schedule you'll never run out dog
people everywhere have ordered more than
200 million meals from the farmer's dog
it's never been easier to invest in your
dog's long-term Health with fresh food
get 50 off your first box of fresh
healthy food at thefarmersdon.com genius
plus you get free shipping just go to
thefarmersdog.com genius to get 50 off
the that's the farmersdog.com genius but
I didn't know this until I started
speaking to her family she goes actually
your Korean is not that bad compared to
other people which I didn't know and
then I started hearing other people
speak Korean in L.A I'm like oh your
korean's bad like you're just really bad
you know because my mom can't speak
English you know and my dad speaks
English but he never does and then I was
partially raised by by Harmony so I had
to speak Korean I didn't have a choice
so I think that helped us out a lot too
because if I couldn't speak the language
I don't think I would be able to have a
relationship with her parents and if she
couldn't speak the language she wouldn't
be able to have relationship with my mom
and
um I actually just talked about this on
an Instagram live where somebody was
asking me like what are some important
things and you know it was received 50
50 when I talked about how important
language is to me
um because
I've seen it with my cousin who's whose
wife is amazing she's dope but her mom
his my aunt his mom will never know how
amazing she is because they can't talk
oh which makes me sad you know so they
think it's like oh do they have to the
reason why the language depart is
important to me is because relationships
are important and I they'll even for for
for them like my his younger brother my
other cousin
doesn't really know his mom like I know
his mom my aunt because he doesn't speak
the language yeah so there's this
miscommunication so I took it upon
myself so when I was younger I used to
get yelled at all the time but I
couldn't understand Korean like very
well right and so I would get yelled at
and I look at my brother like what is
she saying to me
that my brother would have to translate
so one day I just remember like because
me and my parents would fight so much
I was like you know what I'm gonna learn
how to speak Korean so I could talk back
because I don't know what the [__]
they're saying to me you know and so I
started watching a lot of like Korean
like pencils so I would like watch um
do you remember the show X-Men so I will
watch X-Men all the time like Congo dog
you just like all this other stuff and I
would watch it repeatedly right and look
at the translations watch it over and
over and over again now my creative
actually got better and then I would go
to K-Town a lot and I found out too my
Korean wasn't even that as good as I
thought it was even back then because I
only knew how to speak Korean the way
that my mom would speak to me which is
she would curse me out so like I would
like when I would say something I didn't
know how to do like twin them out at all
yeah because my mom like she's from like
the Toledo area so super sure so she
would just
the things that she would say a lot of
people don't use it I don't know I don't
know that yeah I mean like I I only just
recently learned this phrase and what it
meant because my mom would call me and
I'm like I had no idea what it meant I
haven't heard that anymore yeah so I I
asked Mariel's dad I was like what does
this mean and he goes and he's like
you're like the son of a slave like who
said that to you it's like my mom
's like and my friends never heard it
direct translation yeah it is I was like
who said that diesel my mom says that to
me he starts cracking up he goes That's
like old old like that's like something
North Korean people would say but my mom
that's how she would speak and so like I
would always tell people like if I if I
ever speak fluently in Creative usually
I'm cursing somebody out because that's
all I would hear growing up right my mom
one time when now that our relationship
is so much better uh or over the break I
would tell her like you used to say so
many bad things to me when I was a kid
and she was like what and I would just
imitate her my mom would cry laughing
she goes I was like that's pretty bad
I'm like yeah it sounds like you right
so whenever I would uh like watch these
translations like during this time like
I would watch K dramas too and my mom
would say all these bad things like you
know every [__] war that you could
think of like she would she would get
creative with her stuff
I'm like what the [__] am I I would tell
my friends that they're like I've never
heard my mom say these words I'm like
what is it is
is she a gangster I'm like is that
really bad and I would watch these like
movies I'm like that's the [__] my mom
says to me and I remember I called my
mom like why do you talk to me like that
she goes I'm not crazy
you know you don't get it
I I had this one voice oh you're you're
Queen it's very good what is cursing is
really good she used to always say this
to me whenever she would get back he's
like yeah
I would hear that phrase so often and it
was so funny I look back at it it cracks
me the [__] up but I I remember I talked
to my mom and she said this in a very
serious way she goes I was like why did
you talk to me like that she goes man my
life was hard she goes you gotta
understand we were poor we were broke I
had to take care of your grandma your
grandpa you know me and your dad because
of our finance how financially uh tough
in a tough spot we were just like you
didn't know how hard it was for us
because we never told you these things
like we had to take a loan out of our
house to pay for your guys's College
when the economy went the [__] we had we
had to pull out on the house again
um it was during that time where uh
the economy went to [__] and she goes
like we didn't have any money like
people couldn't buy stuff from us like
we had to take a loan on our house and I
was like that's why it took us so long
to pay off this home because we just
kept taking money from the house I was
like appreciative I didn't know this
type of stuff and then I started
understanding oh that's why you were so
mad all the time like things just
weren't good and you know as a kid you
just go oh my parents are just being
[__] they're mean but they're like
no we were struggling to pay our bills
we had to work your father was a pastor
who was
building a church he built a couple
churches in Sacramento he was a deacon
he was going through his he was getting
his Master's in Divinity he was
had to run the store six days a week he
had to take care of your grandma who had
Alzheimer's and then there was you who
just would never do a [__] right now I
was like she was like how would you feel
I was like oh I was like I get it I get
it so I understand you know she was like
yeah you weren't the best kid like you
got into fights constantly every time I
had to see you it was because you were
sent to the office because you punched
somebody stab somebody you did something
and she was like I my life was falling
apart that's so great that you guys were
able to talk about it like that yeah I
mean it
I I I always
people ask about my relationship with my
mom a lot and they're like how did you
end up doing that I was like I had to
just learn how to be a better son where
I had to figure out what she needed and
all she needed was for me to talk to her
and I never did so because every time
she called me I thought she was gonna
yell at me because I was so used to that
so one day and people heard the story a
million times but if you're new you'll
love the story I was in this in my Camry
and my radio broke or some [__] either
way I couldn't listen to music what I
could normally do so I decided I was
like you know what I'm gonna call my mom
so every Friday I'm supposed to call her
and just talk to her just to let her
know how I'm doing but I would talk to
her how any child would not want to talk
to her parents
whatever just same thing you know okay
bye hang on
but I would never call on Friday and she
would those voicemails would come in
yeah
[Laughter]
I would pick up and I'm like and then
she just goes off right so one day I
call her
and then it was like a Tuesday or
something it was some other week that
wasn't a Friday you know she's being
sarcastic she goes oh the King has
finally decided to call this ma why are
you calling me and I had to go somewhere
that was a little far so we just talked
on the phone for like an hour or
something and hung up and the next day
my dad calls he goes what did you what
did you say to your mom I'm like why do
you say anything we just talked to post
she go she's like in the best mood like
she's like so happy and I was like oh my
God I just had to call her she just
wanted to talk I had no idea because I
was so scared she was gonna yell at me
yeah but all she wanted to do was just
talk to her son and after that now we
talk on the phone probably almost every
day whenever I'm in the car I had the
first person I don't listen to music
podcast nothing I call my Mom first and
then we just talk about whatever
um because I know it makes her happy and
that's all that she wanted she just
wanted to talk to her son as an adult
now because I'm not a little kid anymore
and that's when I got to know all these
weird things about her why why she did
this why my dad is the way that he is
because my dad and I don't talk
so being able to talk to my mom actually
helped my relationship with my dad too
because she would tell me it's like your
dad is like this because of this let me
tell you what your dad went through and
then she would tell me about his past
trauma which was nuts by the way he
would never tell me these things right I
would never [__] know there's no way
because in his mind it's
my parents and I got to know this is the
last fight that we ever had and it was
it was so bad to the point where we were
screaming at each other and he said
something very poignant he goes my your
grandma your grandpa my my mom my dad
never spoke to me the way that you're
asking me to talk to you so you're
asking me to do something that's
impossible for me I can only communicate
to you the way that I can I'm a better
version of my parents so how come you
can't understand I was like oh [__] I
don't understand these things so when we
talked about that I was like oh I'm not
empathetic of him so he's just doing the
best that he can he goes if you want to
talk about your feelings go talk to your
mom about that stuff because I can't do
it he goes I don't know how to you know
I only know how to be a leader so do
this because this is the best for you do
this because of that and so now that I
understand that I go
okay this is this is him trying so my
mom would be like yeah like your dad's
not an [__] he just doesn't know how
he's very I was like your dad's awkward
too I was like you know
I'm his very first girlfriend he never
had a girlfriend outside of me and she
goes I chased him down he goes if I
didn't chase him down your dad would be
single and alone he goes that's awkward
and I saw it for the first time in
Thanksgiving I saw him interact with
like people like I was outside of being
a pastor yeah and I'm like Oh my dad's a
dweeb and I didn't know because my
brother they're trying to hook my
brother up with our our friend's
daughter and the way he tries to
teach my brother how to date is
literally the worst advice ever he goes
oh so she knows she likes to drink right
I'm gonna go buy you a martini shaker so
when she comes I want you to start
mixing her drink I'm like Dad that's the
dumbest advice I've ever heard in my
life she's gonna walk through the door
he's just gonna
oh my God
I kind of was you know helped out my
relationship with my parents was like oh
that language and learning how to talk
to them and ask them questions right
yeah you really get to understand them
better right everything kind of the
context that
I forget like they were teenagers they
were kids they had dreams it's hard to
see my parents like that until you see
like these little like chinks in their
armors where you could see them being
vulnerable I'm like oh [__] like I
forget they're people and I think a lot
of like for me anyways I know a lot of
uh fans out there who are young Asian
Americans they don't look at their
parents like they're human beings
because of the relationship that's very
it's like a very
everything they say is so dogmatic do
this do that do this do that and if I
ask them like what do you know about
your parents they know damn near nothing
you know and they go how do you know
about your parents like because I asked
like and they go I can't ask why I don't
know the language I'm like [__] that's
hard so they're stuck
and that's why to me for for a young
generation if your parents do
if they can't speak English to be honest
with you and my personal opinion it's
going to be very hard for you to
understand them there's cultural Nuance
with language
um uh like trying to explain to my
cousin when his mom would say you know
the Korean language is very harsh and
you know like think about this like you
know you flirt with the girl you mess
around
like that literally do you want to die
you know that's how you flirt yeah you
do a direct translation it's like that
sounds pretty bad you know but I had
friends too who didn't understand that
and they're like oh my parents would
always like threaten to kill me I was
like what did they say they would say
like I'm like no
that you're taking it too literal you
know that's how they say anything it's
just a general threat you know and they
just couldn't understand the cultural
Nuance so everything was taken so
seriously so I would talk to their
parents and I'm like
um you're you're misinterpreting it you
know like you're you're not
understanding the culture behind it
because you grew up as an American Boy
and they're still Korean so when they
tell you like when you mess up and you
go
like it's not as hard as you think that
it is right they say that to their
friends you know which was like that's
why like you know anyways like language
is very important I think in my personal
opinion yeah it really is yeah I feel um
you know for you
when
when you deal with uh a lot of like
Asian clients right which you know for
me like I always suggest my Asian
friends to go to you just because
because of that cultural thing
um when I was first trying therapy the
hardest thing was finding a therapist
who kind of understood small things a
lot of it was me explaining things you
know that would take up so much of the
time and even then when I explained it's
just hard to wrap their head around it
and they're trying their best
um
do you feel that a culture plays a huge
part for a lot of like young Asian
Americans when they come to you like how
they process and view the world
I think yeah
yeah very much so
um
I think most people kind of experience
the same thing if they don't go to the
same
um culture therapist they feel often
guest lit like you know you don't have
proper boundaries with your parents why
are you just saying yes to everything
um well that's how it is you know that's
my culture right and so you have to kind
of
um it's not it's not like
you're
you have to educate them in some ways
and that's that gets tiring right so
when you already know right okay yeah
you get you get me right like you you
understand that you know why moms behave
that way or you know why I have to do
this
um stuff like that then it just gets
that much easier and I think
um
also
the familiarity you know
um I think that's also healing too maybe
your therapist could
um pseudo could be a pseudo parent now
right and this relationship will heal
you and it's that much easier if they're
kind of same culture right yeah yeah
because
I think that's the I think a lot of
young Asian women who have that specific
particular particular relationship with
their mom it's very hard to explain
right
um
and I think you know from an American
perspective it sounds
um
I think a lot more abusive than what a
lot of Asian people would perceive it as
right
um
specifically with Korean people they're
like the the biggest issue that I've
always had is the issue of like
Community status and how it navigates
every decision in the family right if we
go here oh how many Korean people are
there do they know us
do they go to church with us okay then
we can't we can't don't drink that glass
of wine don't think we're drunkards or
oh what school did you go to and I just
had this conversation with my mom the
other day we were talking and I was
telling her like one of the things I
dislike about Korean people is
everybody else's business so much and it
irritates me it's like they don't ask
you how your kids are to see how your
kids are they ask your kids to see what
they do for a living and I just like it
irritates me and my mom was telling me
like yeah there's certain people that
you know in our lives like they know
what you do now and they saw that you
were in this movie that you've done a
lot of great things you open these
businesses and they they look at me
funny and I'm like how you guys are like
80 years old like who cares you know and
it's hard to describe this weird thing
that is yeah they care and they ask all
kinds of questions they all they know
all the details I stopped telling my mom
how much I make because she will tell
them she's asked and these talk about it
like oh my you know my son makes this
much money oh my daughter makes sense
yeah stupid that's it's such a weird
conversation like my mom will ask me how
much how much I make and I just won't
tell her because it's like you try to
use it as leverage like what is the
point and like if you ask Mario likes
how I speak to my mom she goes sometimes
I don't know if you're talking to your
mom or your friend right but that's just
how we spoke to each other and this is
why we're so close so she was like so
how much did you make this year I'm like
you know she's like who are you talking
to I was like it's my mom because she's
just asking this stuff and I always tell
her she's so funny where sometimes we'll
still get into arguments where
I'll always tell her like hey
I dislike it when you always blame your
age for doing stupid things I was like
you're not there like I'm watching you
all the time like she'll ask me the same
thing she'll be like how much do you
make how much do you make I was like I
told you a million times don't ask me
that ask me whatever you want don't ask
me about how much money I make right she
goes why can't I and I'm like because
it's inappropriate and just know that if
you need something I got you don't ever
worry about anything else why do they
need to know I don't know I was like I
have a house I have food in my stomach
and I'm working if I'm ever in trouble
just know that I'm moving in and I'll
give you a big heads up she goes I just
want to know I was like
if you ask me one more time I'm hanging
up this phone and then she's not getting
mad right she goes
you know you know she's like I can't ask
you anything
don't talk to me anymore that I don't
want to talk to you anymore and then I
was like okay good tuna come on hang up
and she goes no no like that because you
want to talk to me shut up so like I've
been able to diffuse things a lot with
humor you know but for her she's just
always like places oh I forgot because
I'm old I'm like no no no no no you
didn't forget you try to sneak it in
like I'm like you're not there yet I was
like I know when people are getting old
and they're losing their wits I was like
you you try to sneak it in again and
you're just hoping that I say something
and I'll just tell like a random number
now she goes how much do you make I made
five million last year she goes really
like no idiot like what are you talking
about I absolutely didn't make that
money you think about me that time would
I still be here like are you out of your
damn mind but yeah Korean culture is so
hard to navigate like um
um and every time somebody will ask me
about like advice about stuff it's like
I don't know your personal family life I
don't know how things function so asking
me for this stuff is probably not the
move because it would be like a
five or six conversations over time I
was like and I am not a therapist and
I'm not getting paid to talk to you like
that so you need to go to a therapist
because I can't unpack stuff like that
because that whole background
information just for me going to therapy
I realize how important it is yeah
because all that stuff I would dismiss
it's like oh everybody goes to that it's
like no not everybody goes through that
right you know well yeah I think just
talking about the family culture or
family Dynamic some of them sound worse
than they actually are right like you're
you're explaining it wasn't really abuse
but it kind of it sounds kind of like
abusive when your parents are saying
like you want to die all the time right
but going back to what you were talking
about
um in the beginning the toxic
relationships or you know abusive
relationship
if you had your parents behaving in that
way let's say not not the ones that um
the examples that you mentioned but
maybe they were very abusive to you
maybe they told you you're nothing you
you'll never be anything
um you're ugly like I had clients who
had parents like that every day every
day they hear things like that or they
were physically abused kicked you know
all kinds of stuff I don't know how they
survived really I I think it's really
amazing and you know resilient that
they're here but
if you receive that kind of treatment
and that's what you knew as what love is
right then it's really difficult for you
when you are with a partner who's
abusing you too right it's not that bad
because my mom used to do this too right
oh yeah so they take it because they
don't know any better right
um people might misunderstand that as
you don't have self-worth
well it's not it's some of that too
because you don't you haven't had a
chance to really even develop that in an
environment like that but it's more that
it's been normalized so much that you
don't you don't think it's that bad you
know at least they loved me
oh yeah I've heard that before oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah I've seen that um
it's weird because like I've seen that
before with
um
it's weird how I kind of we picked up
the pieces once again if you just go
back to the family you'll see it right
so I know somebody
um really good guy
and they're together now and we've we've
had one-on-one conversations about this
because he'll
he does that a lot where the person that
he's with right now has
she's sweet right but
she just she's
really [__] annoying you know and you
know I hear him complain about her all
the time and I know her because before
they were married we were you know she's
not really close friends
and you know he would complain to be
about the stuff that she does I was like
listen I know that too but
he goes I wish I could say the stuff
that you say to her like yeah shut the
[__] up like be quiet you're you're
whining too much you know what I mean
like yeah I'll say these things and
she'll be quiet I was like
I could say that because I'm a friend
you're her husband you can't say that
you know and I was like the biggest
problem that you have now is that you're
talking to me about it you're not
talking to her about it right right so
because when I see you in front of her
your smiles is all love but then when
you come to me it's like dude she did it
again blah blah blah I'm like but you
didn't tell her so how does this get any
better right you're not giving your
partner an opportunity to fix it and
just like what you were saying where it
was like him say uh will you hear that
phrase well I've had it worse here not
the dude's mom I was like oh she is the
light version of your mom your mom is
nuts and it pieced together I was like
that's why she's tolerable to you you're
like she and I you know if I've heard
this before in the past where people say
like
young men will tend to find people that
remind them of their mother I was like
well you definitely found that but she
is way better than what his mom is so in
his mind he's probably rationalizing oh
he's not so bad and he said that before
and when you said that oh [__] I he's
literally said that yeah and when I met
him I was like oh this they're kind of
like the same thing but
with with what he decided to do with his
mom he decided to leave and he doesn't
like really talk to her occasionally
here when he has to family events or
whatever and then I see him go over here
it's like it kind of seems like a
repetitive cycle where maybe the certain
things that he sees in her I don't know
comforting because it's what he grew up
around with but I I always just found it
weird it's like you can't talk to me
about this because I can't do anything
for you aside from maybe blow off some
steam right but if you're scared to
confront her about it then probably
another pattern that he had with his mom
too he never was able to talk about
those things with her so he just doesn't
know how to he just walks in a shell and
tried to please her you know by not
saying anything
um
yeah so when you
when you are in a relationship like that
I think those are the things makes it so
hard for you to clear uh See Clearly
right because it's been normalized you
know you experience that kind of
relationship before
um
because we usually repeat a few times a
few times Until you realize like oh you
know what I'm playing a part in here
right oh I'm
I I realize my friend pointed out that
I'm the one who's not saying anything
about it so I have to change so once you
realize that once you do the work on
yourself then you'll be able to choose a
better partner too right but if you
don't work on yourself you don't realize
that or you don't think that's an issue
then you're going to repeat the same
pattern right because he would say stuff
um I did kind of like sit well with me
was
because I asked him how come you're not
and he would say things well you know
she has long days at work I don't want
to stress her out but my mom I'm like so
why is it okay for you to be stressed
out that you know like what's the
trade-off here is it you always
concerned about how she feels and how
her well-being is then who's checking in
on you can't be me you know I'm not I'm
not your you know your wife or your
partner so it's
how does that work you know yeah
that yeah that's I think one of the
signs that your relationship is not
healthy you are not able to talk about
problems
um you feel like your needs has to be
minimized
um
whatever that they think is important or
everything is about them
right
um that's just how I operate because
this Dynamic is that way right
um yeah that's unfortunate but it's more
common than we think yeah I think that's
the the biggest difference because you
know for for a long time on you know on
podcast form or whether it was on your
videos I would talk about situations or
you know recognizing things and they go
well how do I fix this like that's not
my job like I don't I don't know how to
fix it I could recognize things over
time because of personal experiences but
somebody goes like well what's the next
move don't ask me I don't I don't know
I'm not in that situation but you know
like for him because he said that too he
goes oh you recognize these things it's
like what should I do I was like you're
asking the wrong person I don't know
what you should do I'm just noticing
things and I'm not sure if I'm right or
not nothing I say is concrete you know
I'm just telling you from what I've seen
in other people my life experiences and
me knowing this person for 15 years
that's all that I know so I think the
the solution part is where people kind
of get stuck on right which is why once
again I like therapy because there's
tools it sucks when you could see a
problem and then you don't know how to
deal with it at all yeah it's very it's
such a defeating like you just feel
defeated because you see this situation
you know everything that's bad and
somebody just goes fix it how like I
don't know how if we could just fix it
we would fix it in an instant yeah but
being able to
you know have a therapist there to give
you suggestions to give you these tools
to you know like one of the things I
just learned was like like personal
responsibility to a certain extent right
not victim blaming per se because I
think
um a lot of people I think kind of
confuse that right where if they take
personal responsibility it's like well
I'm the victim it's like I think those
are two different things you know
um and I think that
whether it's because of social media or
or whatever happened in the last like
digital age in the last like five or ten
years sometimes personal responsibility
sounds like you're victim blaming a lot
but for me personal responsibility gives
me power it allows me to put myself in a
position to to become better I'm not
saying that I'm wrong or completely
wrong or stuff but it helps me assess
things and I maybe it's because of my
anxiety but I like that control part
where I go okay
now that I've been in this bad
relationship or this person did
something to me that's all on them but
now I'm going to be smarter about how I
assess the situation how did I even get
here yes yeah how did I choose this type
of part when we have individual clients
we generally get their kind of life
history but also relational history and
one of the questions we ask is like okay
so you told me you had this boyfriend
this boyfriend this friend's girlfriend
do you see any common denominator do you
see any patterns they see it they're
like yeah I keep choosing the same
person what's wrong with me yeah that's
another thing we see a lot right we're
I'm like I'm a good friend but sometimes
when I say things it's really terrible
so a friend of mine who um you know over
pandemic got divorced and uh she
introduced me to her new boyfriend and
then let's say this guy's name is Jim
right her previous husband's name is Tim
and then she got so mad at me and then
because we had dinner with her new
boyfriend and I looked at her I was like
so you
are together with the same person just
in a different face huh she was like
what they're so different I'm like no
they're not they're the same person they
even dress the same they talk the same
wow I wish I had a friend like you
she literally just split up with this oh
this was like a couple years ago right
and she was going off a list of
everything she disliked about her
previous husband this person wasn't in
this specific job that made an x amount
of money because I feel like I grew up
really poor so Financial stability is
important for me all this other stuff
and I was like this guy's the same
version of the last guy that you were
with it was different I was explaining
to me how they're different like well he
makes me feel loved and important I was
like so did he when you guys first went
out yeah you know like you said [__] and
then I hate to say I told you she
listens as you know I [__] told you
this but yeah
they broke up and she was devastated I
was like this is the same thing and I
just don't understand like how did you
not see this like when I saw him I'm
like he even looks like him wow you know
it made me feel weird I was talking to
the guy too and by the way this guy that
she was with he wasn't a bad person like
he was actually a really
in my personal opinion we know she and I
were closer we had one-on-one talks too
and I felt in their relationship that
them splitting up wasn't particularly
anybody's fault but I did tell her I
don't know if I should have said this
was
she expected out of him was not
something that he could give and it was
very evident of that in the beginning
because as a friend group we all knew
this about him so for example she was
looking for somebody who was wanting to
take risk and a go-getter I'm like
this [__] was never like that
what were you we all know this we've
known him for years and so she's like he
can't provide that I'm like I I told her
like to be honest with you I felt bad
for him and she goes why I'm like
because he thought that everything was
okay because he was being himself a
hundred percent I was like in all
honesty
you keep saying that he changed he's the
same you changed what you wanted out of
your partner wasn't what you wanted 10
years ago and now that you're expecting
him to be this person it's messing him
up because he's like I thought we're
happy I thought everything was good and
now you're putting this pressure on him
to be this go-getter make this x amount
of salary because of this this and that
but you did it to him out of nowhere and
you went on this trip with your
girlfriend or whatever and I'm not
saying that they yapped into your ear to
make you feel a certain way but
something changed there was a shift that
happened and I I felt bad for him and
now he doesn't even talk to me he
doesn't talk to any of our friends
anymore
um because he was already kind of closed
off as it was and I you know and now too
for her
let's just tell us like look you you got
to know what you want like it sucks for
him yeah I felt this sucked for him
anyways too because I think he felt
betrayed where he thought that he was
the best husband he could be and I
thought so too and but when she was
describing the things that makes her
attracted to a man I was like that ain't
your husband
I was like he's never been that way
we've known him for 10 years or whatever
and I just it's like I said this whole
break of this three-year pandemic it
really it did a number on people I've
I've seen it happen before my eyes I'm
watching Everybody Just explode around
me you know maybe she didn't quite know
those qualities that she's looking for
now were that much important before
um
or maybe yeah
those are the new things that kind of
she learned too right but
um
I forgot what I was gonna say about that
How would how would like like you know
in those situations right
um oh yeah I was gonna say that yeah
that's why I think it's so important to
do the work on yourself so you know you
know what you want you know you know
what's important to you and you know why
you're keep choosing the same people
keep choosing the same toxic or you know
abusive relationship right if you heal
yourself you're going to make the
different decisions
do you feel that a lot of um
once again I'm basing this off of
you know a lot of social because I do
social media for work but
I'll read comments um with a lot of
young women who
this is weird argument that's happening
online where there are women who are
championing this idea of saying like
listen I feel like women are are so
picky with with what they want out of
their partner now it's almost impossible
to find this perfect man there's other
side saying like oh do you want women to
just not have a part of that they feel
like they deserve so one one side of
like the the argument online is there
are women right now who just are willing
to take anything because they're
desperate and the other side is like no
um
I just know what I want and I want X
these things are what's required to be
to be very happy
um and we've seen this like a lot of
numbers of like
um you know people who don't want to
have kids anymore who people who don't
want to be a monogamous relationship
more whether it's like a cultural shift
that's happening right now
um do you have um
have you or have you spoken to a lot of
like women who are kind of in this weird
limbo of
not finding like wanting to be in a
relationship but not finding this
perfect man because I know a couple of
women in my life that are like that and
it's like I don't I don't know what to
say it's like I don't like what do you
want you know I feel like it's like I
don't know what the what the problem or
what the holdup is nowadays with that
well yeah I I do think that there are a
lot of young women who are in that space
um
especially in La I think it's that much
more difficult to find a Suitor who
wants to commit you know like here you
get actresses every single day new
actresses coming in you know um I think
people have that fear like am I settling
too soon you know maybe something but it
will come along
um so there are a lot of Lifetime
Bachelors that I call them
um not bad it's their lifestyle they
choose it's okay but
um that means you know for these women
your pool gets smaller smaller right the
more of these men who are wanting
something different right they're just
maybe wanting to have fun
um not have serious relationships right
now until they're 50 I don't know
um and some of it I think is
um
successful women too have a lot of
difficulty finding their partners
because they feel like
they're going to
um
threaten their partner maybe if they
make more money or if they're more
successful and I think some guys some
guys I think are cool with it and some
guys actually really don't like that I
love it I I pray yeah I pray one day I
could just be a state on Dad
I I I've definitely seen that too where
it's sick up I don't know like a pride
thing right where like oh well she makes
more money than me I would I feel weird
I'm like what the hell please please
make more money there please I beg you
you know I'm waiting for it but yeah
like I I feel like ego makes people very
fragile
um and wanting the best for your partner
sometimes doesn't happen in place of
like your ego right where it's just like
oh whoa
I don't want you to make more money or
be more successful because I'll be
looked as a guy who's like a weak person
yeah because also feel bad if I end up
with you because I'm not as successful
as you are or maybe and another thing I
see is also the age thing
um because guys let's say who are in 30s
why date girls in 20s and 40 they're in
30s right so
the women who are actually in the same
age range who do they date no
they actually want to date their age
group but they can't
um
you know there's like this weird
conversation of
people saying that older women are
really jaded and which I don't really I
kind of understand what they're saying
but I don't see it like that I say more
anybody else who has lived more life
they kind of figure out what they want
and if it's not what they want or unless
they not want need and if the the needs
aren't met why waste our time because
like you know we become more cognizant
of how how fast time goes so
for me I've never liked younger women
because their uncertainty made my
anxiety flare up you know they just
don't know what the [__] they want it's
like I don't know what I want if you
don't know what you want how the [__] is
gonna work you know I hate it I hated it
so like when I I remember
um we would have these like college
shows right and so when these college
shows as a young person they're around
my age it's like two years three years
apart it's all the same it's fine as I
started getting older they just they
started becoming uglier and uglier to me
you know because it became like oh I'm
just giving you advice as a young person
and you not knowing what you want is
sexually just disgusting to me like it
bothers me you know because now it's
like it almost feels like I'm um
I'm a predator where I give them Comfort
because they can look look to me for
advice and then they feel this this
comfort you know and they get really
just
um relaxed around me and that makes them
want to be around me and they want to
hook up or whatever but I'm like this
feels weird like this feels really odd
for me you know I think a lot of guys
really like that I dislike that so much
because I'm not here to be your damn
babysitter like you need to match up to
me right so I remember this one time I
was at this college and then the college
show was over and this guy came up to me
I was like yo these girls think you're
you know they want to hang out with you
they're big fans like they want to take
you to a club and you know drink and I'm
like I'm good and like why I was like
because I'm [__] well at the time I was
like I'm 27. they're 20. we have nothing
in common there's nothing that we could
talk about that would interest me and so
I was like this is what you're going to
do I'm gonna go on say hi I want you
guys to drop me off at this bar because
I'm hanging out with adults and it was
just way more fun yeah it's not to say
that they're not attractive but to me
for what I need it's like I need good
conversation I need to be able to relate
to you somehow and I don't want this
conversation to be me giving you advice
and then you looking at me like oh my
God he knows so much I mean you think I
know so much because I'm literally seven
eight years older than you right when
you become my age you'll know the same
amount of [__] as I will so I never I
understand but I don't I've never been
personally you haven't I just don't like
that preference it just it just always
I don't like it it's not a it's not a
fun time yeah you know um Maryland when
we were in Korea we had this moment
where we realized that
we're older because we were I was
talking to her it was it was me and like
like everybody and Imo's like aunts like
the older sisters and so we were hanging
out and they were telling us stories
about Mariel's Grandma who she's really
really close to and talking about these
stories cracking up having the time of
our lives and then she has a niece who's
like 21. bored out of her [__] mind
yeah and I'm like oh I'm old because I
like this yeah this is the conversation
that I want to have and what the younger
niece wanted to talk about was boring
the [__] out of me I was like be quiet
yeah you know nothing you know so I I
this is that was that [__] for me where
I'm like oh I'm at that age where life
experience
um confidence and knowing who you are
keeping up a conversation is something I
really really appreciate
um when a lot of people talk about
or they ask don't you wish that you were
younger I say no because
my youth was great in terms of me being
able to experiment and try more things
but the uncertainty and not knowing who
I am is something I never want back
right because time helped me build who I
am now the reason why I could speak
about these experiences is because of
time if I didn't have that I would just
be this person who is very and I see
people my age by the way this doesn't
mean like you when you reach the age of
34 or whatever like you'll be at you'll
be here too because I know people my age
who still feel that way but I put so
much time and effort and just either
sitting in a room talking to people just
figure out my thoughts to think about
going back to that person scares the
[__] out of me I can't do it I like I
like much I'm not saying mature a lot of
my conversations are stupid you know but
I like being around people who either
are my or even older sometimes because
the stuff that they could offer in a
conversation and just advice wise feels
really good right you know yeah I think
some women maybe who are single are
going through similar things as you like
they don't want to date 20 year old when
you're in 30s right and then they can't
take 30s or 40s maybe they don't want to
date you right so maybe they end up
um
you know staying true to their maybe
what they want in a partner and so maybe
it's not all a bad thing right
um they they're choosing to be single
rather than being an abusive
relationship or in a relationship
they're not happy yeah it's great yeah I
think being single two isn't bad either
sometimes like
it's great to be by yourself where you
get to figure your stuff out and then
see what you like or dislike
um the online dating thing has been
rough for a lot of my friends because
like people do a great job of writing a
great profile oh yeah
I um
one of our friends too she was talking
about she had a question herself about
whether she felt she was very
superficial or not
and I was telling her no I don't think
you're superficial I think you're
a young woman who were in her low 30s
and you've had bad relationships and
you've had good ones and now you know
what you like so she felt superficial
because she went on a blind date
and I personally don't like blind dates
because I never take out the fact that I
do need the person to be physically
attracted to me right and I think it's
not a bad thing to say that it's a
perfectly fine preference everybody's
different
um and then she met this guy and then
she was like
I feel so bad I was like why I was like
because I just thought didn't think he
was cute at all and she goes am I
superficial is something wrong with me
and I'm like no like you have no
obligation to find somebody physically
attractive I don't understand you know
but because she's been single for a few
years now she's like it's like she's
questioning herself now is there
something yeah
stuff like that yeah yeah yeah and it's
hard for me because I'm not a woman so I
don't know like it's like it's hard to
say but
if you look at somebody once and you go
this is not for me I mean that kind of
means that you know what you want and I
was like well let me ask you and I ask
her this how about this how was the
conversation he doesn't talk at all I
was like okay what's the problem you
know so nothing it was working yeah you
know and I kind of wanted to call up her
her friend who was like set her up on
the blind date and be like what the hell
were you thinking like why would you do
this to her like what what the world is
going on but like
yeah being like a I feel a young woman
now is just it's the navigation is so
different and I've seen this a lot with
um I see these memes where it they
expect women to do everything now where
it's like you can be the woman that has
the six-figure job that knows how to
cook that can be a family woman you can
do it all I was like or you don't have
to right or
or you could just be a normal person and
just choose one yeah you know it's okay
to be you don't want to maybe you don't
want to and they feel like there's
pressure well I have to like in order to
be a badass [__] I have to do
everything no you don't all right you if
you are a stay-at-home mom and you're a
caregiver and you do that [__] well
that's okay you don't have to be the
six-figure job person like Well I this
other girl does does she really do you
know her right because I don't think you
do because they see the the Instagram
whatever memes or whatever I was like
well I'll put it to you like this the
person that you think that's this
perfect stay-at-home mom well guess what
they're an influencer they post a
picture of their fat ass they get a 30
000 check and they stay at home so yeah
they're working and they're also a
stay-at-home mom but they're not working
a nine to five where they're waking up
at 9am going to work at five and coming
back home not seeing their kids your
lives are different and I think that
pressure too kind of [__] up with women
a lot where they're like oh I need to
have a kid now immediately and like well
have you even given yourself the space
and time to think about what you want
like this this is you actually want a
baby yeah do you want a kid yeah right
and if you do want a kid then I think
there's very specific steps for it like
for me I want kids you know and I've
expressed that to my wife before we got
before we got married when we dated and
I I was very straightforward I was like
there's a few things in my life that are
very important I said
family is very important culture is very
important
and also I do want to have children so
if you don't want to have kids you have
to let me know now because I don't want
to invest my time into this knowing that
this is not the end result I think we're
gonna get married but if you just don't
want kids at all then there's no point
right you know I'm not saying now
immediately but eventually I do
and so
you know we we did have a rough patch
where she was like second guessing
quantity to have kids and I think it was
a sobering conversation forever I was I
was upset you know because at that point
we had been together like five years and
I told her I was like listen I told you
five years ago like this is a deal
breaker for me so if I have to leave I
just know it's not because I don't love
you it's because I need this right this
is something that if I don't have a
child I feel like
whether and I told her too I don't need
you to have the kid let's say you know
you're scared
adoption so many other avenues but I
this is a chapter of my life that I need
and like I don't think she understood at
the time anyways how important it was to
me it wasn't just something I threw in
it was something that I need in my life
um but not everybody's gonna be like
that right some people don't need to
have kids and that's perfectly fine you
just got to figure out your own path you
know
well
um yeah we're almost two hours in wow
yeah that one that flew by from fella
with my therapy session but
um if you guys want to contact Liz I'm
gonna have her contact obviously in the
video
in uh in the podcast as well in the
links um hit her up I send everybody I
know to her you know and if not
everybody's going to be a perfect match
but I do
because it lives great all right it's so
kind yeah
um I I feel that if you guys haven't
tried therapy or you feel like you're
stuck in a place where you haven't
really worked on your mental health give
it a try you have nothing to lose all
right just give it a try it may not fit
may not be the right fit for you but
just like anything else although she
tried you're not gonna really know so
hit up Liz I'll have her contact I'll
have her email you could always email
her ask ask questions and then maybe
have a session and see if it fits I'm
always going to be a proponent proponent
for mental health because it's helped me
out a lot if you all think I'm nuts or
an [__] now you should have seen how
I was before therapy so this is the
improved version
um genius brain every Sundays at 12 p.m
um plug-in plug in where they can find
you
um a couple sitting Center couples
Healing Center
um what's your email
Liz weed therapy gmail.com awesome jeans
bring every Sundays at 12 pm we'll see
y'all next time peace
peace
[Music]